and welcome back lovely to see you love
you see what I am again I'm melting
you've never been here
what is that you know I thought that was
the evening purse
no no it's soda bread I made it today I
made it this morning and it's Irish and
I was there as Irish and Irish and I
just thought right I'm cutting you a
quarter of that and that's your check
that it is soda bread cuz it looks like
a giant drug deal of this we smuggled it
in plain sight well that brings up my
cue greaseproof and everything very very
nice whatever that is this week I've
never made it before and say oh of
course
the people versus OJ Simpson
congratulations
yeah really want to go to gloves here
you all are and off words you celebrate
a little that here you are enjoying a
drink and well what the exist another
for the dancing what says great night
out better than
[Applause]
you know nothing to scare us round of
applause everybody
[Music]
you know it's so funny you know you're
backstage after an award show and you're
with friends in the VIP
nobody has cameras because everybody's
got security so you're like doing goofy
stuff back there Marlon Wayans Twitter
dick the next day it was like Cuba
Gooding finger-licking Cuba finger
Gooding genuine good life is about
moderation including moderation itself
oh yeah drink your wine
[Applause]
[Music]
you